when a great role comes around like
right now I'm doing Star Trek James T
Paramount series strange new worlds it's
just that's a lot of work isn't it I'll
be on man is it hard do you like are you
were you nervous because it's only done
one season right it's only done uh yes
it's only done one season we Shot season
two it hasn't aired yet how well is it
going well I'll tell you I I could not
ask for a better cast I mean these
people and and again I'm not a series
regular right so I come in I'm a
recurring and they welcome me with open
arms they are so awesome the showrunner
uh uh Akiva goldsmen is just the best I
just adore him and Henry Alonso Myers
um and they're just like the nicest and
Anson Mount who's the lead I love
answering I just had yeah I've had
Amazon before but I want to have him
again he's just he's just such a good
dude yeah he's really I mean Ethan Peck
who plays Spock is such he's a good
friend of mine I gotta watch this I
actually want to watch this great show
and it's really interesting we play with
timeline so we haven't actually met
James T Kirk in in his real like we we
met an alternate version of James Seeker
we haven't met James C Kirk um as we
know him and from the original series
which we are uh which we will in season
two and um you know I just uh it's
daunting I've gotten to know William
Shatner he talked to him about the role
and everything yeah yeah yeah what do
you say like congratulations you're
playing this right well it's funny and I
said this story I've I've told this
story before I hope Spock doesn't hit
you like he hated me the most bizarre
bizarre thing happened so I shot the
first episode of Star Trek they told me
they haven't announced that they hadn't
announced that I got cast and they said
don't tell anyone whatever you don't
tell anyone I said okay cool I won't I'm
uh I I'm flying from Chicago to L.A and
I get on the plane and I and I had just
binged every episode of the original
series I've watched it all as well right
so I and I look up and I'm like
is that I get on the plane I'm like is
that William Shatner I was like this
can't be and he had just gotten back
from space with Bezos and I guarantee he
was reading a book uh yeah I think he
was always yeah he was reading a book so
but but but anyway so I get on the plane
and I look and I see the seat next to
him is empty I look at my ticket and I
and it's I'm I'm the seat next to him
and I'm like this is this is just like
me well is this is this a candid camera
right he's just like you know Paramount
did something and it's like set up and
it's you know you've got something you
can say yeah not just small talk it's
like I just want to let you know I'm a
big fan and also I'm playing the new
well so I sit on the I get on the plane
I start I'm so fidgety and I we had
actually met spoken on the phone before
because we were neighbors and there was
something and I was like oh I don't know
I'm Paul Wesley I don't know if you you
remember he was like oh yeah right
uh-huh but kind of like it was just like
reading his book as you said right right
and doing a thing I didn't want to
bother him ever people even some woman
was trying to take photos of him and
anyway and we're flying and I'm like
trying to allude to the fact that I'm
playing this role without saying it and
I honestly think he thought I was like
some deranged like I am yeah some like
making I was stuttering I was just in
between you know it was just it was a
disaster I asked him for a selfie and he
was um he was kind enough to to do it I
felt terrible but I said I gotta capture
this moment anyway I get the part uh I
mean I I it's announced that I got the
part and then he you know went on
Twitter and just like tweeted me like
the sweetest thing you know there's just
like this this this this supportive
tweet and just said take care of my ship
you know and it was just like it was
such a beautiful moment and but but it
was like I felt redeemed because I I
really for the for those few months
thought you know he thinks I'm this
deranged lunatic who's like a hardcore
Trekkie who couldn't find his words and
then so when he tweeted me I was pretty
thrilled built and then I saw him and
they invited me to do um uh give a give
an opening uh talk at his handprint
ceremony in San Diego a Comic-Con really
went over there and we chatted for a
while and he was so lovely and how many
people have played James T Kirk besides
him um on television just him so you're
the only one uh other than Chris Pine in
the in the movie in the movie right yeah
yes but
is there some kind of thing where you're
like I need to talk like this a little
bit it's fine I thought should I I had a
conversation with the I had a
conversation with the show Runners and
it was they was they you know they very
specifically said do not do an imitation
of of of the original you know and it's
just you know we kind of laughed about
it but I I wouldn't want to I wouldn't
do that anyway I just felt like um and
by the way I mean I watched the series
and I do think that there's this um
stigma uh that you know that is slightly
exaggerated absolutely you know because
if you watch the series he's actually
he's actually pretty and it's cool very
much so and then and then in the um yeah
he's cool he's smooth he's very charming
and it's just like it's pretty
effortless if you watch the original it
is I love the original I really love it
I think there were 78 episodes yeah yeah
it was a double episode there was uh it
was the one when the wrathicon guy what
was his name oh uh old school I met yeah
yeah he was uh Fantasy Island yeah yeah
his name Ryan Fantasy Island lead guy uh
um the plain boss and he goes it's uh no
I have it I have his name
everybody's saying it right now I don't
want to do without it's like a long name
no I know I know it's like
Montel Montel Montague
Ricardo Montalban yeah there you go yeah
yeah I met him once and I go oh I'm a
huge fan he was older he was in a
wheelchair it was at this restaurant
um and you know there's no one there
except him and whoever he was with and I
it's like oh my God he's like oh thank
you nice to me oh that's awesome he was
really sweet that's awesome that's
always nice when you're kind of the
people that you look at and you're like
oh my God you grew up with yeah and
they're kind